hello everyone and welcome to the third
game will be showing from round three of
the 20/20 candidates tournament is the
leader after round one van Cao against
onigiri who lost his game yesterday and
it's it's quite an exciting game again
I'm not gonna say a lot of preparation
went into it because it it surely did
but I do have a couple of nice photos to
show you so first here we have a nice
photo of Geary in the bank hall right
before the game Geary reaching for
something or maybe maybe going for the
clock and among how either laughing that
something funny Geary said or maybe
suggesting maybe a high-five instead of
a handshake or maybe just a wave it's
hard to say but also here we have an
excellent photo of Nepal mache and
Greece shook instead of a handshake
they're going for the for the elbow bump
which is not only safe but also very
creative as you can see now also here we
have their head-to-head score as you
guys said you enjoyed that so here are
their scores so far so one cow beat an
injury two-to-one with four draws so are
the seven classical games they played
the score is in the bunkhouse favor and
if we include rapid and exhibition games
among Hobbit and Yuri six to five with
six draw so long how better on both
counts so let's see how this game goes
yeah one cow opens with c4 he goes for
the English he replies with c5 he wants
a nice symmetrical game with the black
pieces on Knight c3 and now g6 we have
g3 with Bishop to g7 and now Bishop the
g2 so still going for the symmetrical
setup Knight to f3 and now there are a
lot of popular options here at D 6 e 6 e
5 Knight of 6
Aguirre goes for the most popular one
east since this is played a lot of times
and here castles is the what you would
usually play but if you just Castle
there are over 1100 games in the
database with worldwide just castles so
here among how I decided to include age
14 he says maybe this will throw Geary
off of his preparation however there's a
there's a problem with this because
there is a certain game Magnus Carlsen
played against Wesley so in
last year in the Blitz game where he
also attempted this h4 line with h6 same
as Wesley plate and in that game a
Magnus went for e3 before going for d4
but here among how immediately goes for
d4 we seek after sandy four in the night
the b5 so not nothing new this has been
played but it is quite rare and d5 now
that's not a d5 and d5 now so what do
you do here so see characters on d5 if
you go for the night BT capture son I'd
be capture sandy for right away you can
just trade the characters captures and
after D characters and c4 you have this
Queen to a4 check but it's nothing
problematic for black you will not of
course block with with the Queen because
if block with the Queen Knight d5 is
will will be deadly night c7 check it's
coming and you will not be able to
capture due to the pin
so after this Queen a for check you have
to block with the bishop then you
recapture and okay now the knight is
nicely defended as the Queen no longer
attacks the night but black will be very
happy after look the c8 so after d5 you
don't go for the pawn right away but
instead C capture Sun d5 by one cow
captures and now just castles we have
Knight to f6 by giri
preparing to castle himself and Bishop
to f4 now threatening Knight the c7
trick to win some material so of course
Aguirre castles here and now there is a
game in the database where Knight f
capture son d4 was played adjusting
grabbing that pawn but here wrong how
goes for Queen to c1 it is a new move so
already as a move 12 we have a
completely new game and it's it's a
question what do you play now of course
a giri is here ease up upon but he's up
a double the deep on and also among how
is threatening to capture this pawn here
the problem is if you try something like
King to h7 just defending the pawn which
is a normal move then you allow ideas
like night to c7 which is an instant
draw because your rook is under attack
after you move it you just repeat you
open up a discovery to the rougarou goes
back night again attacks
I don't think long ha would actually go
for such a draw with the white pieces
especially after he won a game in round
1 but who knows and theory especially
doesn't want to go for
since he lost the previous game so I
don't think he would be happy with a
draw even with the black pieces after
only 12 moves so there are some moves
that he could go for he could go for
something like Knight to e4 you could
just give up the h6 pawn as like I said
you are up upon so we would go into
something like captures and the Queen to
b6 you put pressure on the night here
now either a four or captures right away
characters now a4 a6 you click away the
knight Knight back to a3 and now you can
play something like Bishop to f5 Bishop
to g4 and you can start by bringing the
rooks into the game but material is
equal and black has a very active place
so this is one way you could go about it
with with a move like nights to e4 but
also Bishop to g4 is an idea which again
a similar line you give up the dh6 pawn
but at the end of that line your Bishop
ends up on g4 instead of on f5 however
Gary went for a6 he found a way how to
keep his h6 point and give a back at the
double the D pawn but this will prove to
be more troublesome than than just this
giving up the h6 bishop and allowing
black a very active counter play so
giver played a6 and in an interview
after the game Geary said that he wasn't
very happy with it and wang hao said
that he couldn't actually believe that
aguirre played such a move because he
didn't really gain anything out of the
opening but now he felt that he he will
get something so what's happening
tonight B capture some d4 Knight
captures Knight captures and only now
King h7 now defending the h6 pawn and
Geary gave up the double deepen but he
saves the the pawn here however now rook
to d1 now Geary has an isolated pawn on
d5 which is under attack and it's
blockaded so long how will now try to
get more attackers to the pawn rook to
e8 and now Queen to c7 you want to get
this rook into the game so this seems
like a reasonable way to do it you could
try some other Queen moves like Queen
maybe D - Queen C 3
but Vaughn cow says that this endgame
will be favorable for white so Queen
captures and c7 by giri Bishop captures
and c7 and now Bishop to g4 putting
pressure on the e2 born so f3 and now
rook the c8 this is how Gary figured
away how to get the rook into the game
while the bishop is under attack rook
the c8 so Bishop back to a5 and now
better back to d7 and here we have King
f2 just improving the position guarding
the coupon so now the knight on d4 can
move and now we have h5 preventing in g4
also taking away the g4 Square from
White's pieces but now Bishop the f1
bunker wants to play III at some point
and get to this Bishop to a much nicer
diagonal we had Knight the g8 by giri
and bishop back to c3 now saying that
okay if you if you capture I can always
now recapture with my bishop as well
we had rush up to h6 shifting the bishop
to this diagonal guarding the C 1 square
so not allowing a long howl at the
developing of the rook on c1 but rook
the d3 now and also with this Bishop
rook combo you are guarding the e3
square so Ruth the d3 covers that as
well we have Knight to e7 and by gearing
and now comes Luke a to d1 doubling on
the D file as the d5 pawn might become
weak at some point we have Bishop back
to g7 and III now so now the bishop ax
is once again operational although
although not not that much for the
moment King back to g8 and now comes
Luke 3 back to d2 now it's time to shift
the ropes to the other to the other file
bishop to a for forcing the rook to move
you cannot go B 3 because of just rook
captures Bishop on c3 so rook to e1 and
now Russia back to d7 by Erie and now
Knight to e2 with ideas of maybe
shifting the night over to f4 we have
looked the c7 again maybe with ideas of
doubling up on the C file and here among
how it decides to trade the dark square
bishop special character King captures
and now Knight back to c3 so a little by
little one column making progress piling
up on the d5 pawn the rook to d1 could
be an idea now but black gear again has
sufficient resources to keep defending
it Bishop to e6 will cook eat the d1 and
now b5 preparing to dislodge the night
will be 4 so of course among housetops
it with a three and now
rook to b8 preparing to push b4 so Gary
Vanka moves the knight and 92 now before
will not really be doing all that much
and if before you can always push a
sorry if before you can always push a
for to keep it closed so a5 first
preparing it and now we have night the
d4 putting pressure on the bishop here
so bishop back to d7 and now vung tau
goes for b4 he says that i want to keep
my pawn on the dark square you have a
dark square bishop so you will not be
able to attack it and i want to keep at
this point here so it remains a constant
target for my pieces so it captures and
before it captures and now giri uses the
newly opened a file for his rook rook to
e8 with ideas of Luke to a4 he wants to
try and go grab this pawn and Wang Hao
before piling up on the b5 point first
he finds a nice way how to actually go
go after it he goes rock the beat to now
prematurely defends the pawn as he knows
Geary will attack it so we worked the a4
by Geary maybe with ideas of let's say
Knight to c6 either trading of the
Knights but it will be hard to execute
since the knight and the bishop are
attacking the b5 point
so first before going into anything like
that
you cannot capture the pawn right away
even though you're attacking it twice if
you go for example Bishop captures
you're gonna get Bishop captures Knight
captures and now rook just the b7 and
after the knight moves you will win back
your pawn so it's not not an issue
so after this rooked a4 we have rook d2
b 1 now with the defending this pawn
twice and now it's it's black to move
and here giri has to has to make a move
now you will be able to capture because
now the two rooks are already guarding
it so look the b7 will not be anything
after Knight characters for example or
Bishop capture so rook to b7 now but now
the problem is that you vacated the C
file for among house looks so rook the
c1 and now you also have rooked the c5
as an idea to add a third attacker to
the pond while the b2 look nicely
defends the b4 pawn and now giri has to
make a choice whether he wants to keep
with the tension on the board or he
wants to play something like Knights to
f5 and then F
knife characters captures you can still
go rook to c5 but it's not gonna be much
yes now you are defending this point but
now you're gonna lose this pawn so not
not something you can actually do this
Knight to a5 idea
so rook beat a7 Geary says that there's
no there's no way to actually keep
defending the pawn as rook the c5 is
coming so he tries to activate his
pieces this way rugby a7 and now first
we have Knight captures on b5 Bishop
character son b5 not as great because
Weldon just first you trade and then
worked a b7 and we go into a similar
line so we have Knight captures on b5
with Bishop captures on b5 and Bishop
captures on b5 and now rook to a3 for
some reason Geary agree doesn't like
roof to a to actually wants to keep both
rooks on the board so rook to a3 puts
pressure on the e3 pawn may be nice the
5 will be an idea now and then out comes
a bishop the back to e 2 of course this
makes sense you've created a past be
pawn you now have two free free some
space in front of it so you can start
pushing it and now look the b7 Geary
doesn't want to allow this point to
start marching forward he wants to stop
it as quickly as possible so b5 and rook
the b6 you are not crossing the the b6
square and now rook to d1 which makes
sense you want to keep an eye on the
pawn also you don't want to allow this
knife to somehow let's say grow a knight
year night here go after this pawn so as
long as the knight is stuck guarding the
pawn here you don't really have to worry
about losing the b5 point because the
bishop defensive end it's very unlikely
that Aguirre will grab it with the rook
so Geary starts activating the King King
f6 and now rook d2 d2 and here we have
rook to be 7 by giri again here you
could go for Knight to a5 to sort of try
a try and create some chances here for
example if rook captures here tonight
characters here and then rook to d7 it's
it's gonna be it's gonna be an ugly
position for black to play Knight a5 you
can go look for example rogue beat the
d2 and like I said you don't have to
worry about this point the bishop covers
it and it's
a very hard position for black to be in
but giver decides that he doesn't gain
anything by exchanging this pawn so he
just leaves the tension rugby 7 and now
comes now comes Bishop to d3 also also
an idea is definitely g4g for for
example h capture safe captures and now
let's say King to e5 by giri
you're gonna go rook the b4 cut the King
off from the fourth rank still the
people under b5 point and the black
constantly has to worry about you
creating another passport on the King
side so this is this is one of the ways
of on how could have I could have tried
to tackle the position but instead he
goes for Bishop to d3 he has a different
plan
we have Knight to c8 now as the bishop
now blocks the roof so he cannot capture
Aguirre takes this opportunity to shift
the night somewhere else probably
probably with the idea that if just
Bishop back he's gonna go back to e7 and
try and go for some sort of a threefold
repetition but in case that doesn't
happen he just wants to see what a long
hall will play but now long how goes for
efore he wants to get rid of this pawn
so he captures Bishop captures putting
pressure on the rook here rook back to
be six and the now looked at least seven
and here again it's a very hard for a
giri to play this if he's not careful
for example let's say he tried something
like Knights to a 7 to go after the pawn
here Bishop to d5 and it's it's just
just a losing position for black once
they spawn force is going to be just
terrible
so after Luke 37 we have looked the c3
very important taking away the C file
now from from Vonk Hall now and now
comes Luke the b7 now if a bishop here
you can always play Knight to d6 to
guard the f7 pawn so that's not not an
issue so after rook City rook the c3
will rook the b7 forcing the trade of
rooks we have rook captures Bishop
captures attacking the knight and now
Knight the b6 and now the question is
how do you dislodge the night from b6 to
continue pushing your pass on as the
knight is on a dark square and you have
a light square bishop so Vanka retreats
Bishop to e4 and now comes King to e5
and here's the
sort of the moment where you really have
to be careful about what do you do
because in the game Vanka played rook to
d2 but there is a I'm not going to ask
you to pause the video and try to find a
winning idea or anything like that
because it's a it's just an incredibly
difficult idea but I will ask you to
pause the video and just I'm just
interested in your opinion how you would
treat the position what would you play
so you know do do tackle it for for a
minute or two so for those of you who
just decided to tackle it
congratulations on being an excellent
subscriber and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
Bishop to be one seems to offer a lot of
a lot of poison well for for black
because now you black has to play
something you cannot move the night
because the the pawn moves you could
move the rook which you probably will
and well you don't want to touch your
pawns you're just gonna ruin your
position and you don't really have a lot
of good squares for your King and also
rook the c2 will always be an idea
followed by maybe rook the c6 so here
you could go for rook to a3 or Brooke
the c1 maybe even better so now at least
a fluke c2 you can pick up the bishop
but now the point is Bishop to a two you
go after the pawns and this way you kick
the black King back if f5 does just
terrible because just rookie to check
folder let's say rook the e6 at some
point it's gonna be it's gonna be bad so
now what would what you would have to do
after Bishop to e2 is King f6 you would
have to go back but now King III and now
white King gets to go deeper into the
position for example rook c3 check
you're gonna go King to e4 and now again
you have to make a move it's not easy to
find one let's say rook a3 now you could
play rook the c2 threatening this check
to win the night so after King East
seven now you go for the sneaky King to
d4 and this is basically the idea behind
the position and now you give up the
pawn here and after rook captures now
you go rook c7 check King probably
attacks the rook rook captures here you
offer a rook Trey
rook captures and g3 and now king c5
finally reaching this position and well
now it could go either way but White has
excellent winning chances we could just
show for example a line Luigi to attack
the Bishop Bishop to e6 and now rook e
to because the bishop doesn't have all
that many squares due to due to the
night so here you would probably capture
and after characters you would go king
a7 and now you're ready to push your
pawn rook to e4 and now comes to b6
look the a4 with check King to be 8 and
now rook captures on h4 so here black
can be up upon but here b7 and this is
now winning for white because after rook
to a4 you block block the king from
escaping so white cannot push the pawn
you have looked to f6 and now either
either g5 or or h4 doesn't really matter
you can start pushing your pawn white
replies the same route d6 check King to
e7 and now King to c7 preparing the
Queen and after this check Ruby just
blocks in the next movie you get a queen
and of course if just this then you can
pick up the pawn and you don't have any
drawing chances so after King to e5
Bishop the b1 was a I'm not gonna call
it the winning move because it is the
best move in the position but whether or
not you would win it that's you know
that depends on how how you're feeling
today or you know if you would really
grind it out in the end game but Wang
Hao went rook to d2 instead probably
trying to keep the King from reaching
deeper into the position and here we
have looked to be three so allowing the
attack on the pawn here and now Bishop
the c6 and here probably Bishop to d3 is
better and still you have to somehow try
and achieve the same position you had
but among how a decides for Bishop to c6
and now he just allows this Knight to c4
idea
we have f4 with check King to f6 and now
comes Luke to d8 and now it will be
somewhat harder to push the pond we have
worked a b2 with check King to f3 and
now Knight the d2 with check King III we
have Knights to f1 with Czech
threatening to win the pawn here King f3
Knight back to d2 with check King b2 and
now
Knight to e4 with check again I check
from drugs we have to move the King and
the g3 point is under attack so King of
three and it was in this position that
one how and initially agreed to a draw
due to constant checking and well ninety
two check and so on idea to check Knight
f1 NIDA tuna at E 4 and the g3 pawn is
always under attack and of course the
one who doesn't want to give it up so
that's the game a third game I decided
to show you and before I forget we're
just gonna check out the standings after
after the second round of the feeder
candidates tournament 2020 so as you can
see with a point and a half
we have Fabiana core wanna yummy pony
she machine maxime beaugeois graphic all
four of them at least with one well with
one victory in one draw then with one
point alexander grease shock then with
half a point out of two an expiry and
Kirilenko and the biggest price of the
tournament so far Dingley ran with zero
out of two for a 2800 player and not
something you will see often but as I
always say it's just anything can happen
and here you can see that it is
happening so it will be it will be very
exciting to see what happens from here
and someone mentioned that Fischer also
started with zero out of two that maybe
so but it's different when you have a
match then if you beat the other
opponent you don't really care about
there's no one else here it's a
tournament and even if you win your next
game that doesn't stop the other players
from winning their games so it's not
that easy to catch up to them but of
course you know a step in the right
direction is to start winning games
which now with zero out of two I will be
very interested to see how how Dean
pulls it off and if he pulls it off sure
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed the very complicated endgame
that Gibby was able to hold to a draw so
good for him if he had a zero or two
would be also very very hard to bounce
back psychologically I would like to
thank Andre Andre for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament 2020 so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and we can
once again check out that nice photo of
the elbow bump between Nepal and Greece
shock there you have it
citizen